john means 0-2 with an 8.5 era 14 and
two-thirds innings pitch 16 hits
strikeout to walk ratio very good
one-ounce single and here comes conforto
conforto lifts one to left field well
hit back goes mount castle back at the
wall it's out of here
michael conforto with an opposite field
to run homer
number six for conforto and the mets are
out to an instant two-nothing lead
well the ball flies in this ballpark a
fastball away hits straight in the year
by conforto i know he's got a lot of pop
the opposite way but this is
a ball that carries out of the ballpark
so the mets have given michael walker a
couple of runs to work with as he heads
to the mound to make his fifth start of
the year the first four have gone down
in only 11 combined pitches well here's
pedro severino pedro doesn't walk a ton
but his on base percentage is 380 this
year that's 10th in the american league
center field mauriznick racing back
still going still going oh my gosh runs
into the wall the ball is loose severino
around second he's headed to third and
they hold them up there wow mariznick
hit that wall so hard got up chased the
baseball and now my good down on his
knees i mean you could hear the thump
from here i'm surprised he got up he
turns his back and look he's running as
hard and as fast as you can run reaches
up and i mean
face first into the wall you can't hit a
wall any harder than that
so severino with a triple looks like he
cut the bridge of his nose
those glasses would face first into the
wall so here's ryan matt castle with a
chance for an rpi
it's aggressive there line drive to left
that will fall in severino will score
got a little deke from the left fielder
mcneil ryan montcastle with an rbi base
hit it's 2-1 good at bat for velazquez
found some pitches off works a walk and
the bases are loaded mullins comes out
to bed
he hit him it got him got a piece of his
jersey
that's not the one that's not the one
you want to get out of that's an rbi wow
you want to take that one yeah take one
for the club on the jersey well you work
so hard to get ahead two strikes and you
come in this just nicks the jersey is
all it does but it's an rbi my castle
scores the base is still loaded and here
comes anthony santander
2-1 coming and santander gets jammed and
pops it up
canoe trailing out called off by
conforto side retired waka leaves the
bases loaded but the orioles scored two
to get even 2-2 after two the best the
tie-breaking run at first two away after
that first inning home run he has an ops
against left-handers of 950. it's
actually higher than his ops against
righties this year
toward the wall and it's off the fence
rosario racing for third he's going to
be waved around the relay throw by
velasquez to the plate not in time and
the mets take the lead conforto bangs
one off the wall to drive in the go
ahead run and the mets now lead it 3-2
breaking ball that stays up from means
conforto covers it they've been hit with
any elevation that's out of the ballpark
mets were fortunate that it was ahmed
rosario one of their fastest players on
the bases cedric mullins did a great job
playing that ball off the wall getting
it to velasquez who made a good relay
throw but rosario with such terrific
speed able to score especially with two
outs going on contact there able to get
home and give the match the lead so
speaking to steve's point about conforto
against the lefties michael's driven in
all three runs today with a home run and
a double and it's 3-2 new york so now
alonso oh for his last 13 most recently
hit deep to left field down the line if
it's fair it's gone fair and long gone
but it is what is it fair foul what's
the call looks like a home run for pete
alonso and oh boy did he get that up
there that ball just stayed fair down
the line and pete alonso hits his
seventh home run of the year and the
mitts now lead at four to two it was a
change up and it was center of the plate
right down the middle and alonso just
turned on it headed way back into the
second deck deep in the left field
corner no argument from the orioles but
you see how high that ball went above
the pole but the third base umpire ryan
addington had it fair all the way
and that one plunks davis and the mets
have two men on it's just the breaking
ball got away from lakens michael
conforto is it a big day a two-run homer
and a run-scoring double
and he smacks this one deep to right
back osantan there toward the corner and
it's out of here no it's off the wall
check it one run will score as rosario
comes in wide turn by davis trying to
get back to third and he is tagged out
so conforto hit one off the fence that
brought in a run rosario scores on the
double but a two wide turn at third by
davis and he's tagged out trying to get
back in for the second out frazier has
gone over for three in his return to the
mets
frazier pops up
in the middle of the infield who's going
to take it it's going to be the
shortstop velasquez and that retires the
side but conforto's big day continues
third extra base hit fourth rbi five to
two new york japan is the pinch runner
at second alonso at first so here's
marissa
mariznick lines one to center field and
that's down for a base hit jimenez to
third they're going to wave him home the
throw goes to third and jake marisnick
has driven in a run with his second hit
of the day
two on a two out and jeff grounds one
toward the middle of the diamond velenka
can't get it it's off his glove around
third and heading home is alonzo all the
way to third mariznick and mcneil dives
into second base with an rbi double
again the 3-2
and he lofts one over short stop and
that falls for a base in and that'll
bring in another run mcneal is in to
score davis goes to third the fourth hit
and fifth rbi of the day for michael
conforto and the mets now have blown it
open it's nine to two wilson trying to
finish it off
back past the mound knocked down by
wilson he has time and the low throw
skips by alonso and that's going to
bring in a run as valeeka scores
velasquez goes to third now the ball
gets away again and velazquez is going
to come in and score
two runs score on the play as the mets
throw it around
and it's now nine to four that still
have a five run lead dilson herrera
coming up with the orioles still down to
their final out
one two coming
he struck him out and the ball game is
over wilson strikes out three in the
ninth couple of unearned runs for the
orioles but a huge day for michael
conforto with three extra base hits